in shocking but also not really
surprising news we've learned that
Donald Trump doesn't really know the
difference between Medicare and Medicaid
of course Medicare is the program for
health insurance for seniors while
Medicaid is the program for health
insurance for low-income people totally
different programs and six of Donald
Trump's close aides and advisors spoke
to The Daily Beast because they're
concerned that Donald Trump doesn't
really know what's going on with health
care and it's bad some of them laughed
at Donald Trump's recent suggestion that
he both knows a lot about and cares
about health care policy in the United
States and this curve is corroborated by
a recent New York Times story about a
Republican senator who left that weird
meeting earlier this week with Donald
Trump about the new American health care
act with the impression that Donald
Trump quote did not have a grasp of some
basic elements of the Senate plan Donald
Trump appeared quote especially confused
when a moderate Republican complained
that opponents of the bill would cast it
as a massive tax break for the wealthy
according to the New York Times and
here's the clincher a former senior aide
to Donald Trump said to The Daily Beast
that a bunch of times over the last you
know year and a half dating all the way
back to the campaign for presidency that
Donald Trump brand Donald Trump in
private would seem genuinely confused
about Medicaid versus Medicare which is
which what is each do and he would at
times conflate the two and kept having
to be reminded about which is which and
we have a quote here from the former
senior Trump aide as per the Daily Beast
quote there would be times when he would
describe what was clearly Medicare but
say Medicaid and when we pointed that
out he would say that's what I said
Medicare and Medicaid and apparently Pat
and this is the kind of like the saddest
part even though I don't feel bad for
Trump but it is sad aids would sometimes
be afraid of making Trump just look
really stupid in front of other people
so they wouldn't correct him and they'd
let him just kind of like say it and
they would leave it at that okay well
here's the thing those two words are
very very similar it's only the last two
letters that are different of quoting
programs very similar words Medicare
Medicaid so it's easy to say the wrong
one and when someone calls you out on
and all you have to do is be like oh
yeah yeah I met the other one and no one
would bat an eye at that but by him
saying oh that's what I said both of
them actually he clearly couldn't even
take that easy out can't someone just
say to him though Medicare is for old
people Medicaid is for poor people like
I know it's a very crude way to boil it
down and by the way there are also old
poor people who qualify for both and
have benefits from both Trump doesn't
not understand this because he's too
stupid right I mean he may not be super
bright but this is a very simple concept
he doesn't understand it because he
doesn't care and that's why this is so
disturbing even people who have a very
basic general understanding of the
American healthcare system ya know that
distinction that Medicare is for old
people and Medicaid is for poor people
to boil it down to its simplest term but
it kind of doesn't matter I mean that's
that's that's the sort of reality it did
this lack of knowledge or care about
anything didn't prevent Donald Trump
from winning the Republican primary it
didn't prevent Donald Trump from
ultimately being elected president his
supporters don't care that he doesn't
know anything because it's being framed
as well he's a regular guy a regular guy
who started his business with a small
loan of a million dollars in needless to
say his supporters are fine with him not
knowing or caring about stuff they're
already blaming Democrats for Trump
having no accomplishments to date what
happened to all that wall Mexico was
going to pay for stuff anyway I mean it
just it doesn't matter Pat the campaign
promises don't matter the fact that he
doesn't know or care doesn't matter
because Democrats and progressives
really don't like him and that feels
like a victory to his supporters well
Trump would never qualify for Medicaid
or need to rely on Medicare so what does
it matter why would he care about it
right it just doesn't affect them or
very it affects very few people that
Trump has even met in his life I would
venture to say send me your thoughts
about this I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show we'll be back after this I'm
thrilled that today's program is
supported by taga dab the hosting
specialists offering whatever type of
hosting package is good for your
business or project this includes
dedicated and virtual private server
solutions cloud server options which are
increasingly popular as well as custom
servers
Lucian's taga dabs web hosting services
support a really broad range of
customers and businesses around the
world and this includes bloggers tech
startups traders and finance gamers web
developers really whatever you can think
of and you can scale their cloud servers
up or down to meet the particular needs
of your business and to also cut costs
by only paying for what you use
you can save 20 British pounds a little
over 20 US dollars on cloud server
options by going to signup tag adapt
calm /td PS and using the coupon code
TDPS
20 that's sign up ta ga da be calm /td
PS the discount code all one word all
lowercase T DPS 20 check it out